bienvenue à saint cyr en val cette fois
merci mais accueillir les membres du
jury avec des fleurs n'était pas
nécessaire il y en a bien assez comme ça
à saint cyr en val pour plus de 3000
habitants en compte trente mille plantes
saisonnières et pérenne de quoi
prétendre à la plus haute des
distinctions floral la fleur d'or elle
vient elle vient consacrer quelque chose
d'exceptionnel c'est à dire qu'on peut
être au niveau
on est quatre fleurs si on est vraiment
au dessus et qu'on a quelque chose
d'exceptionnel on obtient la flore de
râler fleur d'or sont limitées on ne
distribue pas plus de neuf leur d'or par
an et donc c'est vraiment c'est la
consécration de quelque chose
d'exceptionnel un qu'on a envie de
rester là quelque part ce que jugent les
membres du jury ce n'est pas seulement
la beauté des massifs mais aussi leur
intégration dans le paysage urbain ainsi
que l'entretien des paysages naturels
créé en 1959 pour embellir la france
dans les années d'après-guerre
le label villages fleuris a
progressivement intégrer des critères
environnementaux les modes esthétiques
ont aussi changé autrefois on était
petits on va dire plus ce qui est dingue
bégonias des plantes plus
plus haut niveau du sol avec des coloris
et des variétés - en fin de compte
aujourd'hui on a peut-être 150 variétés
pas vraiment une palette de couleurs une
palette variée talent qu'on n'avait pas
il ya 15 20 en quoi ces fleurs qui ont
survécu à la canicule grâce à des
pompages nocturne on a deux bosses
constitue un investissement précieux
pour la commune qui a besoin de rester
séduisante afin de ne pas devenir un
village dortoir de la banlieue d'orléans
c'est une attractivité attractivité pour
le commerce de proximité
l'attractivité pour les professionnels
de santé
on voit d une nouvelle doctoresse qui
est arrivé il y a quelques mois et qui
est acquis a été attirée par par
l'attractivité de notre de notre commune
c'est l'attractivité des entreprises
les habitants de saint cyr en val
profiteront quoi qu'il arrive de cet
investissement
ils sauront le 9 octobre si cet effort
est couronné par une fleur d'or qui
viendra s'ajouter aux quatre fleurs de
l'entrée de ville